I want to ask you a question so let me
ask you a question why is this movie in
through the old sport I mean usually I
think that when I see 3d movies but why
this movie olds bored it didn't need to
be the Great Gatsby you like my miming
cigarette don't smoke kids it's bad for
you
so The Great Gatsby is based off of a
book that Andy Kaufman himself read to a
crowd of people because they all wanted
him to impersonate Locke and he hated
ladka so he did it out of spite and
that's what I know about the great
gatsby so in this movie Tobey Maguire
plays this would-be author he works on
Wall Street and he lives next to Gatsby
Gatsby was played by Leonardo DiCaprio
and he throws these big parties is
really lavish you're like this guy he's
like the half of his time so behalf I'm
pretty sure they were the same age at
the same time but he's doing it all to
catch the eye of this chick that he kind
of has history with and she's married to
joel edgerton now we have our premise
and Leonardo DiCaprio great in this
movie he's one of the best actors in the
business cuz we're supposed to root for
Gatsby so you're like Leonardo DiCaprio
we innately want to root for him look at
that mug dude is awesome if there was
one dude to root for it is Leonardo
DiCaprio we were all one hair away from
rooting for him and Django Unchained
we're like aw DiCaprio but wait no not
in this movie that would be bad that
would be really bad so we didn't but we
almost did just cuz it was him Carey
Mulligan plays the chick he's going
after she was actually good in the movie
but she starts doing that thing that a
lot of people in this movie do and that
is they overact they exaggerate a lot of
their phrases and their body language
and you're like why are you doing that
and you realize they're doing it because
the director is telling them to do it
you can tell that Baz Luhrmann was like
now everything has to be really extreme
in this movie in parts it kind of felt
like Dick Tracy had a kid with Skye
captain in the world of tomorrow you're
like I don't know if I like that it's
very loud joel edgerton was great in the
movie because you know we're supposed to
root for Gatsby which means we're not
supposed to root for him and you're like
he's supposed to be a dick bag and he
was a dick bag and he was great at being
a dick bag so joel edgerton good job
you've come a long way from being Owen
Lars in that movie that never happened
Tobey Maguire was kind of
interchangeable he could have been
played by
most anybody his role in this movie
would have been like a great big brake
role like if there's some actor out
there in the world who's kind of
struggling to be noticed he finally gets
this role and it was a great break for
him it'd be perfect but instead we have
Tobey Maguire
we all know who he is so we walk away
going there could be employed by anybody
anybody does have a really good premise
as to human beings and dudes and chicks
and ambition and what you have an image
that was really interesting I'll say the
script is probably really interesting so
I'm plot the script in front of me and
they were like read that I'd read it and
be like oh that's cool let's make it a
movie but Baz Luhrmann's the director of
this movie if you don't know who baz
lurman is he's like if Zack Snyder took
an acid trip and started making really
artsy movies however he did read
everybody's free to our Sun screen and
we will never forget that because that
[ __ ] is true in real but no seriously
it's like he got the scripting he's like
oh we'll make this a movie but first
let's drop some acid
oh no let's make a movie it's really
weird I don't know how this dude's mind
works but there's so much green screen
in this movie is so loud you feel like
it's deafeningly loud you hear that
phrase in terms of noise but it does
work in a visual context this movie is
screaming at you so loudly that you
don't even hear what's going on in the
movie you're like what am i watching and
why am i watching it a lot of it's so
loud that a lot of it's boring no movie
that has this much going on visually
should actually make me check my watch
three or four times I didn't want that
to be the case because I was like the
movie sets up and interesting enough
premise and you're like okay cool a
couple of scenes that really stand out
to me are scenes that take place in one
room in which people are talking you
feel the tension escalating that's the
interesting stuff right there none of
the crazy visual [ __ ] going on it was a
clash in terms of the premise of the
movie and the visuals going on they
clash and it compromised the entire
quality of the movie I don't know if
this movie would be like porn to fans of
The Great Gatsby all I know is I got to
say The Great Gatsby is all right but
you're not gonna remember it in t-minus
a couple days yep already forgot or so
are you a fan of The Great Gatsby have
you seen this movie what did you think
of it whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
in the great gatsby told me I can't even
say that in the great gatsby Toby why
can't I say that in the great gatsby
Toby Maguire in the Great Gatsby Toby in
the [ __ ] I can't say that for I can't
leave that [ __ ] together in the Great
Gatsby this is my hole so in this movie
I'm going to say that